ladies and gentlemen Darius Rucker
don't go out with my friends no more
don't wanna hold your hand no more
[Music]
no no I'm not in Hootie and the Blowfish
anymore y'all doing my own thing what do
you mean in Hootie because you you are
Hootie man
[Applause]
[Music]
stop stop I'm now hoody I'm Darius
Rucker all right I used to be the
frontman for a band called Hootie and
the Blowfish all right but I was never
Hootie there was never a Hootie just if
I may if I may ask where the Blowfish at
right guys know people known as the
Blowfish y'all okay the whole band was
just called Hootie and the Blowfish
that's it it was a nonsense name like
Hoobastank or Toad the Wet Sprocket
[Music]
I see I get it now I understand hey we
got a pic y'all we ought to choose
between Hootie or the Blowfish so who
wants to see the Blowfish
[Music]
and what's UT hey and that that hurts my
feelings y'all but you said you weren't
Hootie no I'm not sir but in the
question you just asked the audience I
was clearly Hootie so you are Rudy I'm
not though
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
you